this is the Ori and an Ori is a planet
tracker basically on its own it's a
mechanical way of showing the relative
positions of the planets and this
particular Ori is made for the 10,000
year clock and it has a set of
calculation layers on the bottom and
then a set of rings representing the
planets up above the reason we have an
Ori inside the clock or a planetary
display is that we want to be able to
show the natural cycles of certain
things like the planets so that if
someone were to find this clock far into
the future that they would be able to
look up into the sky see where the
relative planet positions are and
rectify that to the Gregorian calendar
the long now foundation recently moved
into this space that allows us to have
publicly display some of the prototypes
and works in progress for the 10,000
year clock and some of our other
projects you're gonna see some footage
of how how this device was made and how
we moved it into this space which
section ain't no small feat I thought
actually the move today went very very
well considering that
we've moved something that we in Seattle
were used in our shop to having the
large-scale forklifts and brick cranes
and other sorts of things that little
this kind of stuff around it I thought
being able to move it by hand as
carefully as we did came out really
really well putting this in a storefront
is not an easy task
my name is Stewart Kendall I'm one of
the principles called Seattle salsas
where the stone working business up in
Seattle Washington six or eight months
ago that got introduced into the long
now organization through essentially a
mutual friend and one thing led to
another and they had a desire to want to
have a very unusual place for current
clocks being installed in the next room
and I think it's kind of fitting in the
fact that this this rock was shaped to
its current form in the great Ice Age of
about 10,000 years back I think it's
kind of neat to marry that to
essentially a technological piece from
this air on the top that's going to go
the next 10,000 years I mean this new
base that Stewart and Jason built for us
from Seattle solstice and I think is I
think that ducted the position of
this mechanical thing rising out of this
beautiful stone to me it's it really
makes it very I would say the parts for
the orrery were the most challenging of
any of the stuff I've built so far the
adder parts things like the track and
the slider there were not the sort of
normal machine marks you get you know
things of this sort of size there were
big plates they were very expensive
there's a lot of time and money into the
plates before I even touched them just
about the main mill on so this is sort
of the point in which the parts that
they've made the parts that we've made
must made together exactly pretty occurs
it's a proud moment for us my name is
saw Paul of Saba Joanie I'm a project
engineer and the clock of the long now
right now I'm checking the program each
layer has a unique number assigned to
its planet and as the outer layer
rotates it adds this number
from the inside to the outside these
pins can hold the value of 1 or 0
there's 28 of them and after the outside
register has counted up a certain number
of times it overflows and the Geneva
wheel rotates to update the display
layer looks good
like the programs working
I think it's also important because it's
sort of an audacious project to build
this thing that's you know a metal thing
that's gonna be around and working for
10,000 years it's pretty far out it's
pretty outside of just about everybody's
scope I for sure want to see this next
version completed I think it's a very
doable thing and I think when people
start to see
this project in that scale nothing
really will make people start to thing
it's kind of be the best for this to put
it is it's a roundabout way having
people think about their own situation
because if you can get them to think
that far out the future as they kind of
ponder that a place that seems so very
far away it helps them kind of start
thinking about their own future just
even in building it the conversation has
started and I think that's really what
this project is about is it's the
conversation piece